one odd detail that they were talking
about in the news is that the Attorney
General William bar sent the report to
Congress on a cd-rom yes I'm not making
that up there deliver the report on a
cd-rom
do computers even have a CD drive
hundred cd-rom in a long time my mom's
has me yeah of course yeah yeah well the
reason they did this is apparently a lot
of people involved in the mother
investigation are apparently elderly
they're used to an older technology yeah
so they release it on a cd-rom and and
because the people interested are older
it's also affecting how the motor report
is being released to the public this
just came out take a look we're living
in incredible times the news from the
White House seems to change every hour
it's overwhelming
tell me about it and were the release of
the mother report it's going to be even
harder to stay on top of it all well
luckily there's a way to keep track of
all the intrigue and investigation
surrounding President Trump in just four
easy volumes
introducing the mulher collection from
hotel over 80 hours of transcripts
testimony in coats from all the major
players featured in the modern report
with memorable hits like no collusion
there was in fact no collusion it also
does not exonerate him individual one
everybody stop yelling at what we know
stay as she president a lot of great
lawyers like Roy : this is the end of my
presidency um that Donald Trump jr. is
redacted one dumb son of a [ __ ] order
your copy of the Moller collection right
now by calling the number on your screen
call on the next 24 hours and you'll get
a limited edition above
absolutely free order the complete
mother collection today please allow
three to four years for delivery
[Applause]